I want to share with you the comedians
perspective and the comedians review of
Krista Leah's no pain what is up
welcome back I don't do that welcome
back to the hot breath Comedy Network
i'm comedian joel Byers and I recently
did a review of Louis CK's new comedy
special sincerely and a lot of you
appreciated the perspective from a
comedian when looking at these comedy
specials a lot of these videos I'm
seeing on YouTube or more of just like
people that watch with the uneducated
eye so I wanted to share my expertise
with 10 years in comedy and over 200
interviews with professional comedians
all on my hot breath podcast and on this
YouTube channel as well I want to share
with you the comedians perspective and
the comedians review of Krista Leah's no
pain so this special is a masterclass in
the art of smiling onstage unless your
energy is authentically you angry kind
of more curmudgeon onstage like a Louis
black and that's great it works for him
because it's true to him it's
authentically him he's not playing a
facade that is part of who Louis's you
can even see in this clip that he
accents his anger with a wry smile
almost to let the audience know hey
we're still playing here we're still on
this together and in crystal EAA's new
special he not only accents his
punchlines with smiles he'll even go as
far as to actually laugh at moments when
you watch the special you'll see there
are a lot of moments where he's actually
laughing onstage or he'll say a
punchline and then the smile is almost
like a tag to that punchline and it's
very important and that's a big thing
young comics overlooked is the power of
smiling onstage people want to laugh
at people they like which is even why
you see moments where Chris is
physically laughing he's almost just
like hahaha and then the audience is
more likely to laugh as well I mean he's
not going hahaha he's actually making
but the whole verall special is a
masterclass in physical stand-up comedy
and just how important and powerful it
can be to add that new dimension
Seinfeld said the first 10 years of his
comedy
he was only performing from his chin to
his nose so for like 10 years
all his comedy was just coming from his
mouth and his writing but when you add
the physical dimension to your comedy
which is what Chris D'Elia does there's
moments where you're like it's not even
he's saying anything that overwhelmingly
funny from a mathematical sense when you
sense when you look at the math of
comedy writing you're like that joke
doesn't add up mathematically but it's
how he's saying it it's how much he
believes in what he's saying which makes
the audience then believe which it makes
the audience laugh and they laugh a lot
and what's interesting about Chris's
special is a lot of the times you're
seeing in these comedy specials the big
sweeping crane shots over the audience
and then like a comedian making a joke
about women and then it cuts to a tight
shot of women in the audience
it's very choreographed that way but
with Chris's special there are no cuts
to the audience it's really Chris the
entire time sometimes there's some shots
from like backstage where you just see
he's in a huge theatre just a little
minor flex there just to let people know
that you know he's out cheer out chair
out check but overall it's all on Chris
and that's because his face tells the
whole story
he really really really puts on a master
class when it comes to the smile on
stage the physical
presence on stage and even if we take it
to another layer the smile is one thing
but his eyebrows another aspect of the
physicality he brings to the stage
beyond his his expressions and his
exaggerations physically his face alone
you can just learn from watching just
his face and his eyebrows are another
powerful tool he will use during the
special and what's interesting is I just
did an interview with the joke dr. Jerry
Corley who was written jokes for Jay
Leno Bill Hicks Chris Rock and I'll link
that in the description and it's also in
this cart right here whichever side it
pops up on but he talked about working
with George Carlin and the advice
towards Carlin gave him was to raise the
bridge so that was even a difference
between if you say something like this
versus when you say something like this
so raising the bridge means raise your
eyebrows and you can even see how Chris
uses the tool the instrument of his face
tour there's moments in this special you
don't even need to hear what he's saying
you can watch it without audio and it's
just as funny
and that's a good filter to put in your
material through as a comedian is how is
this material coming off a lot of times
we get stuck in the verbage in the math
of comedy and what am i saying but a lot
of the times it can be how you're saying
it as well and how Chris D'Elia says his
jokes in the comedy special note pain I
think it's a much watch a must watched I
think it's a must watch
sorry that's my liberal arts degree
coming out but I think it's a must watch
for comedians looking to add physicality
to their performances I don't care if
you're doing a five-minute set at a
coffee shop where it's the barista and
the host and that's all it's at the show
or you're getting ready to film your own
comedy special
you can always be learning and using the
instrument of your body to add a new
dimension and a new layer of laughter to
your so that being said yeah I hate
everything you know
you know I'm looking at my notes right
now yeah that was a good one that was a
good review right there I'm feeling good
about these reviews or did we're on
Louis CK's and now Chris D'Elia is let
me know in the comments what special you
would like me to review new we're old
famous are not famous let me know what
kind of specials you'd like to see me
starting to review on here please do
subscribe if you find this information
helpful this whole show this whole
channels all about helping you learn
comedy from the pros so subscribe to the
YouTube and we'll see out there hot
breath the verse out there wares out
there I don't know it's only my second
one all right I'm getting better okay
but thanks for watching it smile hey hot
brethren and sistren if you love comedy
as much as we do here at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath averse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy
hips high breath